استهداف الكرملين كان متوقعا منذ فتره
قصيره لكن السؤال هنا ما هي داعيه
المحتمله التي قد تتبع هذا الهجوم ما
ذكرته نشرته نيويورك تايمز قبل نحو ثلاثه
اسابيع الصحيفه الامريكيه حصلت على وثيقه
استخبارات سريه من بين وثائق البنتاجون
المسربه تتحدث عن اربعه سيناريوهات للحرب
في اوكرانيا واحد هذه السيناريوهات
استهداف الكرملين بضربه عسكريه اوكرانيه
الوثيقه التي تعد تحليلا اجرته وكاله
استخبارات الدفاع توضح ان الهجوم الذي حصل
اليوم قد يؤدي الى تصعيد الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه في حال اقدم بوتين على اطلاق
تعبئه عسكريه واسعه النطاق والنظر في
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه ومن
اتداعيات المحتمله للهجوم على الكرملين
ايضا ان تدفع مخاوف الشعب الروسي بوتين
الى الجلوس لطاوله المفاوضات للتوصل الى
تسويه تنهي الحرب اما الاحتمال الاخير فهو
الا يحدث شيء جوهري في مسار الحرب
[موسيقى]